قال رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان ان الجيش السوداني لا يملك
قوات كافيه لايقاف العنف غربيه دارفور
وحذر البرهان من انتقال الصراع في بلاده
الى دول مجاوره قال ان مجموعات متمرده
تنطلق منها وتبحث قائد الجيش السوداني ضمن
جولته الخارجيه مع زيلينسكي بشان ما وصفه
بالمجموعات المسلحه المدعومه من روسيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما مدى وجاهت مخاوف
البرهان من توسع الصراع في السودان الى
خارج البلاد وما الرساله التي يوجهها الى
الاطراف الاقليميه والدوليه من خلال ذلك
وكيف نقرا الاجتماع الذي قال زيلينسكي انه
ناقش فيه مع قائد الجيش السوداني ما وصفه
بالجماعات التي تساندها روسيا وما دلالات
حديث البرهان عن عدم وجود قوات كافيه من
الجيش لوقف العنف في غرب دارفور وهل يمكن
للاطراف السودانيه ان تضع حدا للخسائر
البشريه خاصه في تلك المنطقه واي فرص للحل
التفاوضي في ضوء تاكيد البرهان في جولاته
الخارجيه على افضليه الحل السلمي وبالنظر
الى مدى استعداد اطراف القتال لانجائحه
واي مسؤوليه للمجتمع الدولي اذا اما يحدث
[موسيقى]
اصبحت تهدد السلم والامن الاقليميه
والدولي هكذا وصف رئيس مجلس اسياد
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان الحرب
الدائره في بلاده من على منبر الجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده تحذير كرره في
لقاءات جمعته في جولات خارجيه بدول عده
معنيه بتطورات الحرب في السودان مشيرا الى
انطلاق ما وصفها بالمجموعات المتمرده من
دول في الاقليم لم يستبعد ان تتسعى رقعه
الحرب لتشملها في حال لم توضع نهايه سلميه
لها البرهان شدد على خطوره الاوضاع غربيه
دارفور مؤكدا ان الجيش السوداني لا يملك
قوات كافيه لايقاف العنف هناك نتابع جانبا
مما قاله البرهان
طبعا هذه المجموعات المتمرده اتت من دول
كثيره في الاقليم
لذلك هذا الصراع سينتقل الى تلك الدول
حتما اذا انتهى في السودان او اذا توسع
خارج السودان هنالك مقاتلين من معظم الدول
الجوار
البرهان التقى ضمن جولته الخارجيه التي
شملت المشاركه في اعمال الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده التقى الرئيس الاوكراني
فلودي مرزلينسكي الرئيس الاوكراني قال ان
الاجتماع بحث الانشطه غير القانونيه
للمجموعات المسلحه المموله من روسيا
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى من باريس الكاتب
والباحث السياسي السوداني
ابراهيم ادريس الباحث المختص في الشؤون
الافريقيه مرحبا بكما سيد محمد تورشين هل
محذر
البرهان منه هو خطر فعلي يتهدد دول
الاقليم بامتداد وانتشار الحرب اليها اما
انه فعليا حاله خطاب في منبر دوله اراد
البرهان من خلاله الاستفاده من هذا المنبر
من اجل ارسال مثل هذه الرسائل حول هذه
المخاوف للمجتمع الدولي
بدا التحيه لك ولشاده المجاهدين الكرام
ولضيفك الكريم انا في تقديري ما ذهب اليه
البرهان في اطار محاوله لعكس صوره للمشهد
في السودان باعتبار ان
السوداني يجاور عدد من الدول التي تعاني
من الهشاشه الامنيه والاضطرابات السياسيه
بدا من اثيوبيا مرورا بدوله جنوب السودان
افريقيا الوسطى اشات وكذلك ليبيا فبالتالي
نستطيع ان نقول كل دول الجوار السودان
تعاني من اضطرابات امنيه وسيوله سياسيه
والمشهد الذي حذر منه البرهان عاشته
العديد من الدول على راسها افريقيا الوسطى
النظام الرئيس الاسبق فرنسا
2013 استطاعت عدد كبير جدا من الميليشيات
كذلك ميليشيات جزء منها سوداني ومن جاد
وكذلك من النيجر ان تشارك في تغيير النظام
الامر الذي اسهم في دخول البلاد في حاله
من والحرب الاهليه وتكرر المشهد ايضا في
ليبيا وعندما سقط النظام معمر القذافي
هنالك عدد كبير جدا من الجماعات المسلحه
الان التي تشارك في الحرب في السودان كانت
مشاركه في الفوضى التي عاشتها ليبيا فضلا
عن ذلك هنالك محاولات ايضا حفيده من بعض
الحركات المسلحه تستعين بالفصائل المسلحه
من السودان وكذلك من افريقيا الوسطى
لتغيير نظام الحكم فيه انجمينا لذا في
تقديره باي حال من الاحوال اذا تم
القضاء او محاوله لحسم المعركه في السودان
العسكريا ربما هذه الاثار والتداعيات
ستجمل دول الجوار باعتبار ان هؤلاء
المقاتلين الذين الان يقاتلون في صفوف
الدعم السريع سيعودون الى بلدانهم سواء
كان في افريقيا الوسطى او كذلك في
بعض المجموعات ربما تعود الى الى ليبيا
الامر الذي يسهم ايضا في تعقيد الاوضاع
الامنيه والسياسيه في تلك البلدان وربما
ايضا خطاب البرهان والاشاره لهذه الجزئيات
الغرض منه ايضا
استشعار الخطر
وتوضيح بان المجتمع الدولي اذا ظل يقف على
مسافه واحده من قبل طرفيه الصرع ربما هذا
الامر يهدد الامن والسلم الدوليه لا سيما
الدول الاوروبيه باعتبار ان السودان يعتبر
من اهم الممرات التي تتدفق بها عادات
كبيره جدا من اللاجئين القادمين من القرن
الافريقي وذلك سيسهل بشكل كبير جدا نتيجه
لانشغال الحكومه بقضايا الحرب مع الدعم
السريع ربما في مرور عدد كبير جدا من
المهاجرين وكذلك في تدفق الشبكات التي
تدير الجريمه المنظمه وكذلك القضايا للجار
بالبشر والسلاح حتى الجماعات الارهابيه
يمكن ان تتسلم نتيجه لانشغال الدوله
السودانيه بهذه الحرب وربما تعبر الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي فكل هذه القضايا ربما هي
قضايا
سيد محمد طورشين للسيد ابراهيم سيد
ابراهيم وعليه هل ترى بان هذه التحذيرات
من هذه السيوله الامنيه العابره للحدود
الاقليميه للسودان من على منبر الامم
المتحده هذا
ستلقى اصداء لدى المجتمع الدولي خاصه بان
البرهان ايضا اكد عليه في جولته الخارجيه
التي كانت منذ ممتده منذ شهر تقريبا
في تقدير البرهان مثله مثل كل القاده
الافارقه اللي بتواجههم قضايا تاريخيه
محتقنه فيما يخص ثلاثه قضايا اولا قضيه
الحدود الاستعماريه وما سببته من اشكالات
بين الدول المجاوره هذه الحقيقه الاولى
الحقيقه الثانيه ما يسمى
اللي هي القوميات المجزئه هذه القوميات
المجزئه
ضعف الاستاذ توروشين في قضيه السيوله بين
هذه الشعوب هناك تداخل حقيقي
وملموس في السودان كما هو في الكونغو
رواندا في ازمه الصراع الاني الحاليه ايضا
الايثينيه هناك مسجه وعليها تتم هذه
الخلافات اثيوبيا ايضا بحدوده مع الصومال
ومع اريتريا ومعه جنوب السودان وايليتريا
مع السودان ومصر مع السودان كل هذه الدول
اثبت في التاريخ هذه التداخل والاشكاليات
او ما يحتمل ان يكون القضايا المؤجله
الان يشيل لها السيد البرهان في جولته
الشامله اللي هي شملت الدول العقليه وكانت
بذكاء محدد في انه يتضمن فيها دول بعينها
كالجنوب تحديدا ومصر واريتريا لما لهم من
اثر مباشر في عمليه العسكريه والتحولات
العسكريه وهذه السيوله التي ذكرتموها في
هذا الحوار
عسارتها الان
هو حقيقه هي قضيه ليست البرهان مختصه بها
كما بما ان السودان ايضا واجه هذه المشكله
في مرحله الصراع في دارفور ومساله مرحله
الصراع في الجنوب وايضا الاشكاليات
الموجوده مع دول الجوار الاخرى او التك
حولها
عليه القضيه قضيه اساسيه وهذه السيوله
المتحركه ليست ستقف عند هذه النقطه حيث
هناك قضيه اخرى تغافلتها الكثير من الجهات
المراقبه بان الحكومه السودانيه سمحت لدعم
السريع ان يصدروا بطاقات هويه
لقوه غير مجهوله في تاريخ الهويه
السودانيه وتعريف المواطن السوداني هذه
الفقره هذه التجاوز
ادانيون مجنسين في هذه المرحله الاخيره هل
هم الذين اتوا من النيجر
ومناطق دول غرب افريقيا ام لا هذا هو
السؤال التاريخي الذي بلاش السودانيه
وجلسوا جلسه تاريخيه وناقشوا قضاياهم
الجزريه والتاريخيه بما سيد الاجابه هذه
اذا برايك بانه يعني ستلامس مثل هذه
المخاوف المجتمع الدولي سيد ابراهيم في
يعني جمله واحده هل ستلامس هذه الهواجس
المجتمع
وتش السودان هي المنطقه المرشحه بشكل
مباشر سيد محمد طرشين
كثيره طبعا هي الاضواء التي سلطت على يعني
عن احاديث حول دور روسي محتمل
في هذا الملف المتشابك خاصه باتجاه دعم
قوات الدعم السريع ويعني ادل على ذلك هذا
التقرير الذي خرج قبل فتره من شبكه
هل يمكن وضع ايضا لقاء البرهانكي ضمن هذا
الاطار الاقليمي الدولي حول هذا الملف
المتشابك
وفي حقيقه الامر طبعا العلاقه بين السودان
وروسيا هي علاقه قديمه او وصلت الى مراحل
متقدمه بحيث ان الان كل الترسان او معظم
الترسانه العسكريه لاسيما الطائرات
العسكريه من السوخوي والميكيوم ومنظومه
تسليح روسي لكن بعد هذه الحرب وانا في
تقدير ربما اعاده الغياده السياسيه
والعسكريه النظر في جدول هذه العلاقه لان
روسيا لم تتدخل بشكل واضح وبشكل معلوم
لانغاز منظومه الصراعات الدفاعيه لاسيما
الطائرات العسكريه التي تساقطت مرات عديده
وتقديم حلول في الاتجاه الاخر نتيجه لذلك
نجد ان روسيا
بالاخص دعمت الدعم السريع بصواريخ ارض ارض
وارض جو والتقارير وكذلك العقوبات التي
فرضتها الخزانه الامريكيه وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه اكدت ذلك وحتى التقرير الذي صدر
مؤخرا بان ربما للمسير التي الان فاعله في
السودان هي نتيجه للتكنولوجيا اوكرانيا
فربما البرهان الان يستغل التعاطف الدولي
الاسيوي من المجتمع الغربي سواء كان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والاتحاد
الاوروبي في دعمهم اللامحدود للجانب
الاوكراني فبالتالي ابداع التعاون ودعم
القضيه الاوكرانيه باي حال من الاحوال
ربما يغرب البرهان اكثر لتلك القوه الدولي
والاقليميه المهمه فبالتالي يمكن ان يحصل
على مزيد من الدعم لازمه فيما يتعلق
بالطائرات المسيره لان السوفت وير الذي
تعمل به هذه الطائرات المسيره ما هو
اوكرانيا فبالتالي من السهل جدا ان يتدرب
عليه للطيارين السودانيين او الذين يديرون
غرف تحكم هذه الطائرات المسيره ويمكن ان
يحقق من خلاله انه محاوله المضي في
المشروع السياسي بحيث انه من خلال هذه
التصريحات وخروج البرهان في جولاته
الخارجيه يبدو ان الرجل لا طموح سياسي
وهذا الطموح ربما لا يخفيه في كثير من
اللق
انا انا اتوقع انه العلاقه بين السودان
وروسيا لن تكون كما كانت لان الان فعليا
السودان يعتبر هو محور مهم جدا للجانب
الروسي واعتقد ان عدم مدير السودان قدما
في تنفيذ الاتفاقيه الروسيه السودانيه
التي تم توقيعها في العام 2020 وتم
اجازتها حتى من مجلس الدوم الروسي لكن
الجانب السوداني لم فيمضي في تنفيذه
عن يعني دخول مثل هذه العناصر على المشهد
في الملف السوداني هل يعني بان الملف
سيذهب باتجاه التدوين ومن هي الدول
المعنيه غير روسيا مثلا بهذا المشهد
السودان يعني
الجغرافيا السياسيه اذا رضينا اليها
السودان ليست جزيره السودان دوله متاخمه
مع دول في افريقيا السودان امامه البحر
الاحمر واللي هو يشكل في الاستراتيجيه
الدوليه احدى مراكز الصراع بين القوه
السياسيه والاقتصاديه عالميا ثلاثه
السودان له جذور في علاقات ممتده تاريخيا
ايضا في منطقه الخليج العربي
ومن هنا ثلاثه عناصر العنصر الدولي
والاقليمي والمباشر في الحدود مع السودان
يرشح الى علاقات مضطربه انا لست متخوف من
ان يكون السودان له علاقات او امتداد
الاخرين تجاه السودان كما للسودان تاريخيا
السودان دوله تاريخيه السودان دوله تمثل
محور اساسي في المجتمع الدولي في كمؤسس
لهذه المنظمه الدوليه منذ الحرب العالم يه
الثانيه السودان
مؤسس للجامعه الدول العربيه السودان جزء
مؤسس للاتحاد الافريقي ماذا يعني يعني ان
السودان له علاقه متجذره في هذه المحيط
حوله سيؤثر ويتاثر الان هو في موقع التاثر
اكثر
القوه السياسيه اصبحت مفقوده من هنا
اللي هو
لتفاعل بعض الناس قد يفهم متعدد
العناصر اللي سالتي عنها هو عناصر واضحه
جدا انه
الامريكان بما لهم من وجود عسكري واكرر
كلمه عسكري في البحر الاحمر واهميه الصراع
الايراني العربي مع وجود ايضا تشاحنات في
داخل منطقه البحر الاحمر تجربه اليمن
كقضيه دعت القوه السياسيه ان تتحالف ويكون
لها قدم يكون داعم للحوثيين او مواجه
للحسين ماذا يعني هذا هو السودانيين ايضا
شاركوا في هذه الحرب يعني ان السودان هو
جزء من هذه المعضله المتازمه وهو الضحيه
الاساسيه في هذه المرحله الكل سيعمل من
اجل تحت شعار توحيد السودان دعم السودان
في التنميه ايجاد ودعم انساني لمحاولات
راينا
المنظمه الدوليه بعثت مندوب كبير اساسي
الى هذه المنطقه لمعالجه وتفعيل دور
الامم المتحده الامريكان بقياده
تمارس سياسه عميقه جدا في في مفاصل القوى
السياسيه في السودان
الامريكان راينا لهم علاقات واضحه مع قوه
تغيير مع الجيش ومع حماتي ماذا يعني هذا
يعني انه المجتمع الدولي ككل ستكون له
مخالب في السودان وازمه السودان هي انه
عول كثيرا على الخارج
بينما كان يتطلق ان يعالج مشكله الداخليه
كمحور اساس وضمن هذا الحديث سيد محمد
البرهان ضمن خطابه ايضا اتحدث عن اهميه
الحل السلمي ضمن عمليه مسار تفاوضي كحل
سنه لكنه في ذات الوقت تحدث عن يعني عدم
قدره الجيش على وقف العنف غرب دارفور ماذا
وراء هذه الاشاره الى عجز الجيش على فرض
امن معين مطلوب في مناطق يعني هو المفروض
انه يسيطر عليها في منطقه غرب دارفور
تحديدا
وعموما المؤسسه العسكريه السودانيه فشلت
او عجزت عن توفير الحمايه والامن للمدنيين
سواء كان في ولايه غربي دارفور وهي من
المناطق الاكثر تاثرا بالحرب جراء الجرائم
والانتهاكات التي وقعت ايذاء مدنيين
والمقابر الجماعيه التي تحدثت عنها البعثه
الامويه في السودان وكذلك عدد كبير جدا من
القتلى حتى الان مجهولين الهويه بالاضافه
الى ذلك مدن دارفور عموما سواء كان وسط
دارفور وحاضرتها ازاليه او جنوب دارفوع
وحاضراتها نياله وحتى الخرطوم ام المناطق
التي تاثرت كثيرا بالحرق نتيجه لتمترس
الجيش السوداني في مواقعه وفي قواعده
العسكريه دون الانتشار في المدن وكذلك في
المناطق الحيويه من اجل حمايه المؤسسات
والمنشات وحمايه المدنيين وهذا القصور بلا
شك تتحمل مسؤوليته المؤسسه العسكريه
والحكومه
لانه من الاشكاليات التي ظلت تعاني منها
المؤسسه العسكريه انها لم تستقطب او تفتح
باب التجنيد لعرض كبير جدا من الافراد عقب
التوقيع اتفاقيه في العام 2005 فضلا عن
ذلك
الذي حدث من قبل المؤسسه العسكريه او منح
الفرصه للدعم السريع للتجنيد اكبر قدر
ممكن من الافراد بالغاء الماده الخامسه
منها قانون الدعم السريع الذي كان
يوجه الى كل التحركات وكل العمليات
العسكريه ان تتم في اطار القياده العامه
وهيئه الاركان المشتركه للمؤسسه العسكريه
السودانيه هذه الجزئيه حقيقه ان اذا كان
البرهان يدرك هذه الجزيره فهذا تصريح بان
المعركه في السودان ربما ستطوله تاخذ وقت
اكثر مما هو متوقع باعتبار ان الان بهذه
التصريحات يعترف القران بان الموارد
البشريه للجيش السوداني هي محدوده في ظل
عادات كبيره جدا من عادات للاخوات الدعم
السريع في ظل انضمام عدد من حركات الكفاح
المسلح
بعض الحركات التي وقعت على الاتفاقيه
للسلام وبالاضافه الى ذلك بعض الحركات
التي قدمت من ليبيا ففي ظل هذه المعطيات
انا في تقديري ربما يكون خيار السلام هو
الاغرب لكن لا يمكن
لان الوقت يعني ادركنا سيد ابراهيم على
حديث السلام طرحت مبادرات عديده من اجل
وقف القتال يعني هذه المبادرات لم تصمت
كثيرا مع مثل هذا الحديث عن تدويل واتساع
رقعه القتال هل لا زالت هذه المبادرات
صالحه ام يعني من الممكن ان نشهد مبادرات
جديده واطراف اخرى تدخل
كان هناك
تفاعل في نيويورك يقود الدكتور سامح سادس
شكري وزير خارجيه مصر في اللقاء في دول
الجوار والدول المعنيه من المجتمع الدولي
بهذه الازمه للوصول النتائج انا من الذين
يؤكدون على هذا الفشل في داخله نجاح بدا
يستثمر بعد لقاء القاهره لقاء القاهره حيث
اجتمعت الدول الجوار وهي في هذا البرنامج
يعني اكدتم بهذه الاسئله الذكيه في هذه
المرحله متناسبه مع الواقع انه هناك
بالفعل دور فاعل للقوه المجاوره عليه
اتفاقيه او لقاء الخطوط العامه التي توصلت
لها الدول الجوار في القاهره وفي انجامينا
في المرحله الاخيره والنهارده وبالامس
اللقاءات اللي قاعد مكثفه في نيويورك بلا
ان شكل ستجلي لنا بحلول عمليه لاسيما ان
البرهان موجود في نيويورك ومره
بهذه الدور فاعل في هذه التجربه القوه
السياسيه السودانيه ايضا بدات تتفهم هذا
الدور في الحلول العمليه
بزياراتيه الى اسمره وبذهاب كتله
الديمقراطيه الاخرى
قحط الى اديس ابابا
عن ثنائي هذا او في محاوله التقاربات التي
بدات والدور الارتري المصري الفاعل في هذه
الفتره الاخيره ينبغي ان هناك من المحتمل
ان نرى بصيصا من النور وفاعليه عمليه ليست
كما راينا في تجربه جده وهي تجربه محموده
وتجربه قطع الصوت كثير لكن ليس كلي اضافه
اض
افه الى منظمه الاتحاد
هل تتفق مع هذا الكلام سيد محمد يعني في
اقل من دقيقه
هنالك محاولات حديثه من القوه السياسيه
وكذلك الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني لكن
انا غير متفائل لان حتى الان القوه
السياسيه غير متوحده او مواظبه غير متصقه
مع بعضها البعض وان كان الكتله
الديمقراطيه ومشاركتها في ازمره وكذلك
مخرجات التي خرجت من ازمره او الحريه
والتغيير المجلس المركزي او القوه التي
تجتمع في في كل هذه القوه بالاضافه الى
انه هنالك فوائد اخريات الكتله كتله
التغيير الجذري بالاضافه الى مجموعات اخرى
كل هذه المواقف غير غير منصهره في رؤيه
روميه وتستطيع من خلالها انها تفرط رؤيتها
وتمارس اكبر قدر ممكن من الضغط على
المؤسسه العسكريه وعلى الدعم السريع حتى
يتم التوصل الى دفعهمات وانما ما زالت
القوى السياسيه بنفس الافكار ونفس المبادئ
التي سبقت الحرب فبالتالي انا لا اتوقع ان
تكون هنالك عمليه سلميه في مضى المنظور
وربما هذا
يكون متشائما كثيرا لكن هذا هو يعكس
الواقع بان القوه السياسيه حتى الان لم
تقدم التنازلات اللازمه من اجل طرح مشروع
وطني بشكل او باخر في ايقاف هذه اشكرك من
فارس الكاتب والباحث السياسي السوداني
محمد تورشين ابراهيم ادريس الباحث المختص
في الشؤون الافريقيه شكرا لكم مع المشاركه
معنا لونا تنتهي الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر دمتم بخير والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]